so my name is Christine broadridge on
the education director of Chris which
the Center for Research on interface
structure
what is that it's a Materials Research
Center so what you're going to learn
about today is a very interdisciplinary
field that's part of material science
but what you'll find is material science
is involved all many different types of
science and engineering aspects and so
that's something that you're going to
learn about you're in for a real treat
we actually have back by popular demand
dr. Corey o burns so we actually did
this lecture last semester and what
ended up happening was it was the same
day at Hillary Clinton was actually in
town so I think if we had done that
today you probably wouldn't had to worry
about it
right you would have peter out
definitely longer so so what Laurie is
going to do today is he's going to talk
about the missions of st. so dr. Auburn
is an associate professor in the
department so I have to read the South
because there's so many things that he
dubs mechanical engineering and material
science applied physics physics as well
as the graduate program and
computational biology and bioinformatics
which is a really exciting field those
of you out there are thinking about
different fields that are growing all of
these fields are growing but I think
bioinformatics is one that's
particularly exciting to me before
joining the faculty at Yale dr. Kern was
a postdoc a postdoctoral fellow at UPenn
in physics he did computational studies
of jamming transitions and frictionless
granular materials and glass transitions
and models glass forming liquids okay so
you're going to know more about what
that is after this demonstration and
today dr. Auburn's received a PhD in
physics from the University of
Pennsylvania in 1999 he'll probably tell
you a little bit more about the type of
research that he's done he did his
undergraduate degree in Duke University
and in graduated in 1994 with a BS in
physics you see with the physics degree
how much he has done throughout his
career he's an excellent teacher as well
as a mentor to many students so with
that I'm going to thank dr. Auburn and
let me take the floor so again they're
in for a real treat
thank you can you hear me
before I go on I have to introduce my
second hand man
this is Tebow Bertrand doctor Timo
Bertrand he graduated in May with a PhD
in mechanical engineering and material
science and he's going to be helping out
sort of 5050 with all the demos and talk
today so yes so I'm Corey O'Hearn and
I'm gonna be talking about the mysteries
of sand and so let's talk more about
that so sand is a part of a general a
more general class of materials called
granular materials and what is granular
mean means made up of small grains if
you think about it actually everything
is made up of smaller grains your body
is made up of cells that's smaller than
you the chair you're sitting on is made
up of atoms if there's a key a key
distinction so up here I have water
that's not a granular material the
components in water are little water
molecules and they're very small a
nanometer is the relevant length scale
there whereas here I have sort of
garden-variety sand and the components
of sand are these little sand grains and
they're not a nanometer they're more
like a millimeter or a centimeter and
that size distinction makes a world of
difference
and then we're going to be talking about
granular materials like sand where the
components are things you can see so
here are little particles but they're
not sand they're the size of a micron so
that's if you look in a flower and you
look at pollen don't look at the
aggregate of pollen look at just a
single pollen grain pollen grains are
about a micron big and when things are
that small they move without any without
any other forces they're not moving
because you're making them move they're
moving just because of temperature and
so here I show you a picture of small
grains they're not moving because I'm
pushing on them they're just moving
because they're small these are called
thermal fluctuations and so anything
above this size anything above a few
microns basically anything you can see
with your naked eye are granule
materials and they don't move unless you
push them so we're now gonna play a
little game I told you what a granular
material was I told you what wasn't a
granular material and you have to tell
me if the pictures I show you our
pictures of granular materials this
isn't going to be the next game show on
TV is this a granular material what is
this what is it don't you don't have to
be quiet you have to be as loud as
possible what it's salt is it a granule
material yes because the grains you can
see you can see the important grains of
this material what's this glass is this
a granular material why
well there are grains there are atoms
but you can't see them okay so for
example glass is made of silicon dioxide
molecules and you can't see them the
next one I think you're really gonna
like this is my favorite cereal is this
a granular material
yes it's fruit loop so you can see those
those fruit loops
what's this smoke so this is not a
granular material if the smoke is made
up of air and other you know nasty
chemicals it's not a granular material
okay so that set of slides that was
really fun what you see from those
slides are you know what a grand of
material is and what it's not they're
all around you so look at some of these
pictures and see if you recognize any
granule materials I really like candy so
I immediately see the M&Ms I see some
rotini I see my ibuprofen that I take
all the time I see coffee beans I see
rice Grandda materials are all over and
so we need to understand the fundamental
aspects of storing moving handling
granule materials and because they're
made up of macroscopic objects that you
can see it causes a world of problems
but also interesting phenomena and we
have seven or eight demonstrations which
are going to illustrate these points
first I'm going to talk I'm going to try
to motivate those those demonstrations
so the first is you know here I'm
pouring water water conforms to the
container it's in water is a liquid and
you can see when I pour it out of this
vase what is that called
whatever I'm pouring it and it's flowing
it's not stopping and then it goes into
the other container and conforms to that
container so this liquid this water is
not a granular material but this is kind
of confusing here we have an hourglass
our glasses you know you can put sand in
an hour
but the problem is is that this granule
material is possessing both solid
features and liquid features at the same
time where is the liquid feature yes let
me let me translate that so it's sort of
solid at the top but then when it goes
through this orifice through this hole
its flowing like a liquid I can prove
that it's now the thing that's confusing
about it being sort of solid at the top
and solid at the bottom is that a liquid
can do that a liquid will conform to
them the container it's in but then it
will pour and it's not in that shape
anymore but what you see at the bottom
of this hourglass is it's forming a cone
a conventional liquid does not form a
cone it would just form a flat layer so
the fact that this is forming a cone is
proving that this grainy material is
acting like a solid it's not just
avalanching and falling forming a flat
face remind me when I'm done with this
section
okay so here's another example one of my
students really liked Starbucks coffee
and so wanted to carry out a
demonstration of when the system is
behaving what a granule material is
behaving like a liquid or a solid and so
try to figure out when it's behaving
like a liquid and a solid so here you
see it's intermittently behaving like a
liquid and a solid
when it's flowing through the container
it's behaving like a liquid when it gets
jammed and stuck when it forms this Jam
it's behaving like a solid and so this
is both interesting and caused a great
consternation what if I wanted to flow
grain of materials through some tube I
would never be able to predict when it
would get stuck or when it wouldn't
okay we have actually examples here a
little Brendon journals that we packed
up and those bottles just like the video
that you just saw and we're gonna see of
the floor knots and that's actually a
whole field of research there's people
you've been where Cory did in speech D
that are studying that everyday just
studying how we're in a material jam in
those constructions basically called
hopper flows here I have this blue
bottle with a pretty large opening on
top and little star shaped plastic beads
in them I have another bottle with glass
pebbles I have a bubble with a smaller
opening with little wooden beads and
then a non ticket Victor's bottle with
coffee beans in it and I have this same
blue bottle with little glass beads
those are very very small you can see
them here the question I'm going to ask
is do you think they're gonna flow do
you think they're going to jam so let's
start for example with this little glass
beads there are 500 microns about the
millimeter intervening diameter and they
are in a pretty big opening if I just
start pouring its will it just flow or
will it stop flow let's just do it
okay I never got to to gem this okay so
one important variable that you have to
consider is the ratio between the
particle that's inside and the hole it's
flowing through and think about what
that ratio has to be for it to get stuck
does it have to be one it doesn't have
to be one in fact good guess so let's
think about yes I mean let's do it let's
prove it so now I have coffee beans in
this in this bottle what about those
coffee beans any idea I would say the
ratio in between the size of the coffee
bean right here I don't know half a
centimeter a centimeter and the bottle
oppening is once
for any idea is it gonna floor enough
flow yeah kind of slow down but never
really stumped so that one is flowing
what about now these little wooden beads
there's third variety of sizes in there
but they're all about a centimeter and
the opening is about two so it's one to
two is that gonna flourish I can stop
it's somewhere in the middle and you're
saying three but what could it depend on
right now all that we've done you know
coffee beans are pretty pretty spherical
like beads the lower velocities were
very spherical these are also there's
variable what could it depend on what
could this ratio the man on you're
saying three that may be true for these
fears but maybe it's not true for these
little star shaped particles maybe it's
not true for those glass pebbles because
they're their shape is completely
different so there's a lot of things
that can go into that there is shake of
the particles and that's always the case
in granular materials and we'll show you
in this in a second but shape goes into
in the balance
friction in between the in between the
particles goes to in the balance and
we're gonna be talking about that in a
second next one those peddlers and the
pretty big blue jars stop poor flow stop
this one just what about those they make
one comment is that it's interesting
that that one flowed because if you take
one of the dimensions of those discs was
fairly big and it was comparable to the
opening size but they completely flowed
out so shape is a very important plays a
very important role the last one are
these little star shaped particles are
they gonna stop or are they going to
flow stop you always see stop
that's just salt I can tell them a bit
and you give them to close the study of
is it gonna flow is it gonna jam is it
going to stop is an actual industrial
problem
think about your production line when
you're in pharmaceutical company and
your whole these fields Fleur know or
even your eminence your candy company
you've got all this M&Ms flowing now how
can you control in all those production
chain the fact that it's gonna stop it's
gonna jam its kind of stuff flowing or
it flows to get in your package and get
to the concern that whole problem cost
actually a lot of money and that's a
problem that's on the research right now
okay just to further motivate that so we
talked about these hopper tests we're
gonna show you a little more in a little
while which tells you when is the system
behaving like a liquid or a solid here's
another example that granel materials
can behave like solids here the this is
an intricate sandcastle that's being
formed the way the reason why this can
be formed is that it's wet we're going
to talk about that in a little while but
it can form these very 90-degree angles
which is amazing little trivia question
does anybody know what's the tallest
sand castle that's ever been made like a
world-record tall sandcastle in the
india guesses ten feet
tell me 15 feet so we have better 20
feet
30 feet but are you fine well it's it's
actually about 14 yards so it's actually
55 feet or something like this or 50
feet something 14 yards so we mention
about I would say about twice the height
of this room maybe a little less that's
the that's the tallest sandcastle that's
ever been recorded so this those kind of
materials in the proper conditions can
act as solids they can they can be so
standing they can support some sort of
weight and some some some sort of load
okay so the next thing we're gonna talk
about trying to understand whether
particular granule materials are
behaving like solids or liquids is
what's called a slump test so try to
remember that you can impress your
engineering friends this is this is
often used in the concrete industry to
determine how well the concrete is
performing but what we're gonna do is
we're gonna pour out different granule
materials and see what type of conical
shape that the granule material forms as
it is poured and so we can measure the
average angle of the cone so it's
basically the the angle that the the
cone is making with the either the
vertical or the horizontal surface so if
this angle if you're measuring it from
the vertical is ninety degrees then it's
a liquid it'll be a flat surface and so
we're gonna we're gonna study that the
other the other thing is the the less
steep this conical angle is the further
that the material will flow so there are
two measurements that you can make with
these slump tests you can measure what's
called the angle of repose which is what
this cone angle but you can also measure
how far the run-out is after the Sun
test okay so we're going to do for slump
test now so we're gonna do some tests
here with different materials and
as there is here where we tell you that
I told you a second ago as the nebula
ripples as a lot of stability quantities
in green materials to that what tells
you if it's a solid or a liquid depends
on the shape of the particles depends on
the friction depends on the density
depends on the size of the particles so
here are completely different Granero
materials the first one is just regular
long grain rice okay the second one is
going to be our favorite coffee beans we
already used and then I have two types
of sentences I have a red sand and I
have a white scent farther than the
color the main difference between these
two guys is that one of them not namely
the the white scent is a little coarser
a little bigger the white scent is very
very fine I can actually pass that
around if you want if you just look at
them this is going to be very important
in a few minutes and another
demonstration so we're gonna be playing
another game here and I'm going to ask
you what do you think flows best the
very fine red send this like coarser
white send the coffee the rice what's
going to form a pile that has the
biggest expansion and I'm gonna do it on
this pieces of paper right here so I can
mark out after we did the slump test
with a sharpie and we're gonna have a
look at them so keep that in mind but
I'm gonna take a couple answers what do
you what do you guys think rice is gonna
flow the best though the least the most
okay so rice number one does everybody
agree yeah the red cent is going to flow
the most okay so we've got here right
someone else thinks red cent right here
do we know anybody else basically
someone is going to tell me coffee and
the other ones not to me white cent
right so for now we have no idea so
that's that's let's have a look but
let's keep in mind that we basically
have someone who told us rice which is a
big gray
it's also allocative it's pretty smooth
it's not very frictional someone who
told us red sandwich is very very
fine-grain it's a powder and it's also
like course there is lots of friction
between the grits so I'm going to do
them one by one and we're going to start
with let's start with the rice white
Center I'm just going to pull the cup
it's going to form a pile and we're
going to look at how big it is okay
where is this show right here so it
makes a pretty pretty nice file it's
actually a nice conical shape just like
you saw on the slide I'm just like that
was in the power box and I'm just going
to mark up the size right here it's
about that big I'm gonna do the rice now
no way a little bigger maybe the red
cent
the red Sun was I'm sorry not a good
answer
the red Sun is actually for now you're
gonna see in a second it's the smallest
of the planets
it's the the list expended and the last
one we have is coffee beans okay I don't
see it on the hood so those roll better
exactly so if they take really the
extent this is a coffee beans okay let's
just get rid of the material I'm just
going to put them up on the board and
we're going to compare the sizes you
should draw a smiley face on
what you say yes we are we're recycling
the grain by grain okay so if you look
at what's now on the board can everybody
see properly basically what we are
saying is that the best floor is the
coffee beans
that's far in front of the other comes
next I would say like probably to rice
white and the red the white same and the
red cent
and this different scenarios in between
the white center the resin is very
important is this difference in angle
we're closed except as I was telling you
coming from the size of the particle the
friction between the particles and so on
but it's actually creating all the
problems that you see all the time in
industry when you mix powers of
different sizes the problem that we're
gonna see is called segregation so here
I have an hourglass that I basically
filled up with the red a mixture of the
red and the white scent okay and I'm
shaking it it's very well mixed there is
a problem do you see a structure in it
it's completely mixed okay
you can check it a little more right
here and I'm just gonna tip it I'm gonna
let it go and when I see it just okay if
you start seeing seeing something let
let us know what it is you're saying you
can see that yes can you see something
at the bottom those of you who are in
France what do you see
you know that's that's true and the
reason the reason why it's doing exactly
what you're saying and also switches
from the left to the right a little bit
it's because it's reaching the sights so
when it's reaching the sights it cannot
flow more on one side so that is gonna
be piling up leaving some space on the
left so it's gonna come and fill in the
left and then the like so it actually
fills it up layers by layers but is
there anything else you can see here I'm
trying not to but it's match it's
completely layered I started from
completely mixed distributions of those
particles and just going through an
hourglass and just because the angles
are proposed of the two materials are
slightly different ever so played with a
couple centimeters you've actually have
nice layers nice stripes here so can
anyone think of a problem that this
would cause if you're processing granule
materials so one thing that can happen
is in the pharmaceutical industry if
you're making a pill and the the
medication powder has different
properties in the filler of the pill
then maybe some pills won't get any
medicine
so you want in many situations you want
mixing two systems to remain mix and
this in this system what happens and
hopper flows is if there's any
difference in the materials the
materials will segregate into a material
that's all similar and another material
which is similar okay
we haven't talked too much about
creditor material as a solid and what's
actually holding it together I mean you
guys it's it's you've been this summer
maybe to the beach waste in the beach or
or have an asset nearby you can welcome
to the beach you can walk in the center
I'm gonna both with snow liquid when
you're going water you can't walk on
water
oh there it is a problem with quicksand
but that is a slightly different pattern
on normal sense if you have an asset you
probably won't find quicksand you can
anymore you can walk on top of a dune
and not and not fall through
what's holding your weight what's what
are the forces at stake and greater
materials that make those pile is solid
we took we took away all those Wumpus
that we did if I love them until the end
of the administration they would be
still - here they are not flowing
they're completely stable so now the
question is what makes a great material
what makes it a solid core do you want
to know let's do this report first
so all those brings all these piles are
made of little wings that are willing
contact okay they're all touching each
other and that this contact there is a
repulsive force meaning that I cannot
push particles together without applying
the force and there's also friction
which means I cannot push them up and
down without applying a force those two
forces are critical in Graner materials
and this forces and other materials are
actually not propagating the same way as
they would in a normal elastic solid if
I were to take a little piece of rubber
and push on it all before the forces
would go damn in the same direction and
pushing in the granular material explain
the difference they're propagating along
those contacts in
all the grades and I'm going to show you
should show you that in a second what I
have here is a to t-mobile brand of a
journal that's my grandma turtle right
here all these beads right here all
these a little disc but you see that we
cut out of a material that's called
photo elastic photo is for let elastic
for elastic this material has the
awesome property that the amount of
light that goes through depends on the
amount of stress or amount of force is
under okay so in the experiment I'm
going to show you the warm light you're
going to see the more forces or stresses
variance in the particular grade okay so
the problem is that as you can see
there's nothing going through all the
light is going through well there's a
little trick to it I'm gonna have to the
polarizers around it to actually see
that's manifestation polarizers are
nothing else than what you have in your
polarized sunglasses that give you look
at the screen of your iPhone or their
spend on your Samsung Wave polarized
sunglasses what you see are those skier
distance colors there's like rainbow you
can't really see your screen very well
well it's because polarized sunglasses
are only letting the light go P in a
specific direction so it's exactly what
I'm going to do here I'm going to be
filtering the light in one direction by
the first polarizer I'm going to be re
filtering into the second bars
I'm joking up to be sunglasses on my
experiment to be able to see what's
going on inside daesil
okay so you guys are starting to see
something now you're starting to see
that there is little strikes in it okay
little parts that are darker and little
parts that are lighter those are the
forces in the system it's exactly other
forces are propagating I'm going to take
a plotter I'm gonna push on the system
we're going to look together at what it
looks like
and everybody see my on the way off
anybody let me just go and be on the
side so you can see better everybody can
see that okay can tell Kenneth can
someone just describe what's what's
what's inside all the forces propagating
everywhere in the same way you yeah
that's just what I sent them before
that's perfect basically the more forces
in the material the more light you're
gonna see but do you see the same amount
of light everywhere and the every green
no no that's what we call chain forces
in render materials there's something
that's peculiar about this material
that's not happening of liquids it's not
happening in a continuous media like an
elastic solid the force is not
propagating the same way everywhere
there are actually those chains that are
reaching out from widely different parts
of the material and providing the
stability and those change horses are
exactly what you see in this little
experiment right here so for instance
this chain of light that you can see
right here is one of those train chain
forces linking the top wonder with the
side okay now not only those forces are
kind of reaching from the batteries to
the plunger here they're linking all the
particles together and some complicated
way they're also frictional they're no
if I were to take these two grains and
put him next to each other just lay them
next to each other there is a force
that's associated to that and that's
exactly what I was going to show you now
okay now we're gonna we're going to talk
about force change but we're going to
talk about its consequences in a
material so right here have a dowel
wooden dowel in here I have sand and
here I have a glass beaker so the glass
is in the glass beaker and I'm going to
force the dowel into the sand
kids you need your parents permission to
do some of the things I'm going to do
okay so this is a common so here's a
demonstration so what's what would be
interesting is you know originally the
doubt was separate from the sand
there's no contacts it was the dowels
outside then I shoved the dowel into the
sand and the dowel is making the the
grains are making contacts with the with
the dowel and the force chains are
connecting then the DAO the sand to the
beaker side there's all these four
streams that you saw in that propagating
existing in this container and if those
four chains are really strong if they're
making strong connections between the
grains between the down of the container
I could pick up this dowel and and
everything would be picked up with it
because these force chains are
connecting everything do you think that
this will work okay we have some yes we
asked some knows okay and in its and
it's all about what's the surface area
of the dowel like is there are there
enough contacts on the surface what are
the size of the grains what are they
frictional how heavy is the beaker how
have incense so it depends on a lot of
variables didn't work okay I knew that
wasn't going to work okay now we have I
would let's do this one first with me
what I'm gonna do is how many I'm gonna
get on here he's gonna hold that thing
over me and see if that works
let's just just get it over with
what are you doing now what I'm doing is
I literally just compacting the grains a
little bit so that when it goes down
more forces more contacts are made in
between the devil and the grains and
through the grains to the outside so I'm
just compacting the this a little bit to
gain a bit of stability I'm going to
pass quickly come on a second time okay
but it gets better we're gonna have a
little competition so we have two of
these what we're gonna do is we're going
to pass them up and down the aisles and
what you have to do is make sure that
this doesn't break so this allows you to
see what's going on but also you know to
sort of feel the the integrity of this
so this so what was the difference
essentially nothing I mean but this is
now not glass it's just a 2-liter bottle
plastic so the same the sand is a little
coarser and the dowel has a greater
thickness and so we tuned the variables
a little bit and now they work it's
purely dry there's no there's it's just
dry sand it's not cement we're gonna
talk about cement in a second but these
are just dry okay you're going to the
left I'm going to the right to UM
careful it's a little heavy okay so if
you don't feel like you can carry it
just pass it to ever once it and don't
fight for it because if you shake it
it's if it breaks it's okay we'll start
over
we'll just watch this for a little while
just one thing careful not to shake it
too much when you pass it to your
neighbor
I'll explain you well we'll show you in
a second why
I can take it over if
yeah here you go okay where's the black
one okay could I get it back Jimmy well
we'll keep it we'll keep it up after
that the demo with fear once you uh play
you can you can try it out and see if
you can pick it up so we're gonna move
on to buoyancy so so just one thing we
said we said this is held up with all
those chain forces okay this is very
stable right now but let me just tap on
the side and I'm gonna break all those
chain forces thanks out on the side I
can just take it out okay buoyancy so
we're just talking about the solid
properties of of granular materials but
they also have liquid like properties
and so one thing that you all know about
especially if your swimmers is buoyancy
and so buoyancy is related as a force
that causes things to move up in water
it's proportional to the density
difference between the object and the
fluids you're in so in the case of this
water it's going to be the density
difference some dense the the structure
is that you're putting in and the
density of water now so
let's try this so if something's buoyant
it's going to float and that means that
you know there's a density difference
between the water and the object so this
is a foamy golf ball is this thing gonna
float or not there's a tricky one
this these are beads but they have a
hole in it for these these plastic beads
are they gonna float are they gonna sink
here are those disks like rocks are they
gonna float or they're going to sink
okay so this is basically you can use
this experiment to measure the density
of an object we have a couple other we
have a ping-pong ball and this is now a
real golf ball that's gonna sink a
ping-pong ball it's gonna float because
the density of a ping-pong ball is
essentially the density of air and
that's about it so the the next thing
you can do is ask can you do an
analogous experiment in a granular
material the first answer would be know
that you're going to try this experiment
and the the object is just going to sit
on the surface because when the granite
material is not being agitated as not
being vibrated exactly like a solid and
so the density is very high and so now
we're going to do a buoyancy experiment
but we're going to agitate we're going
to vibrate the granite material and it's
going to act more like a fluid and so we
can measure the density of objects using
granular materials
and I'm also going to be using just one
of those way to use those patient
weights okay there the lid
they're pretty heavy if I what is this
wait here
heavier and denser then the greater
material and I am here we're not this is
just glass beads but I have in there is
it okay so normal buoyancy experiments
in a normal liquid what should happen
they should sake at the bottom this is a
ping-pong ball as core was saying it's
about the density of air because the
shell is very very much what should
happen in this case should float okay so
now if I just put this two guys on my
render material just going to put them
right here
well the don't thing to actually be
doing much the the weight is not going
to the bottom the ping-pong ball is on
the top that's where it should be it
should be flowing okay know what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna sink this
ping-pong ball in okay I'm going to keep
this weight up when I put another couple
weights and another ping-pong ball then
I'm gonna sink in okay
when I sink in this ping-pong ball what
do you see what's happening they're not
coming up in the water the wood in the
brains are not any idea why
the longest icon top yes and the pink
Mobile is also staying on there the
reason why maybe up there tell me yeah
these biggest brains aren't activated
it's because there's all these street
forces we talked about those greens are
frictional they act like a solid they
are here and they're keeping the
material as a solid and they're keeping
those ping-pong balls stuck at the
bottom and while the people would like
to rise up because they're less dense
this force this buoyancy force is not
enough to overcome the forces in between
the grades it's not enough to break
those change forces okay but we can help
them a little bit I just told you that
it's stuck because all the greats are in
contact so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to shake this thing I'm going to
shake it up with just a little this is
the equivalent of your speaker you have
at home nothing more I'm just going to
shake it pretty pretty fast and pretty
strongly to break those contacts what's
going to happen is that all those
particles are going to come the plot I'm
just going to break those conflicts and
reset them and what let's look at what's
going to happen
okay and I'm gonna stop it right here
what happened anyone just speak up
mmm think exactly if you want you can
say melting I literally with this
shaking I just made the liquid out of a
solvent so lots of Mainers were back
like in the water case and my ping pong
ball raised up and the heavy objects
that were on top those weights those LED
weight just fell and sucked at the
bottom now what you see is that one of
them became up really fast because you
know I I told you the chain forces are
not exactly stable the same weight
everywhere so that one just raised up
because in the channel is probably more
fragile around it the other one did not
the other one is actually stuck in the
middle well I can tell you that right
now
I stopped the shaking the contacts where
we made the forces are reestablishing in
the material it's now selling again
which means that I can wait here forever
and we can see that in an hour when
you're done with all your demos outside
this is gonna stay here the bull will
not rise to top unless I actively shake
it unless I make of this material ill
liquid again from the solid okay
so what we were talking about for most
of the previous time was dry granular
materials so when we were doing the
dowel test when we were doing these
vibrate this vibrating of the grain of
materials the systems were dry there are
two ways in which granule materials can
behave cohesively and so a cohesive
material you can actually pull apart and
it'll resist you can tell that this
system is not behaving cohesively
because I just pulled grains off the top
and it didn't resist me at all so dry
granular systems are what's called non
cohesive there are two ways to add
cohesions
well they're more than two we're going
to talk about two one way is to add a
little bit of water and I drew it
schematically here
here we have you know just a little bit
of water and this you know about when
you when you make sand castles you add a
little bit of water to the sand if you
add too much it's not good you make a
slurry and then the sand castle falls
apart but you add just a little bit of
water to form what are called liquid
bridges between the grains and they act
cohesive so the reason why that happens
is because fundamentally water it has
surface tension water molecules are
sticky and you can illustrate that with
this experiment which I hope will work
you can do this at home you have a cup
you're going to put a little water in it
and then you're going to put a top
cardboard is usually pretty good if you
use paper papers a little too flimsy
what you want to do is make contact
between the water and the cup and the
top of this surface and then turn it
over in the cohesive force of the water
the surface tension of the water will
keep it up when I flip it over and don't
add too much water
oh you saw it there for a little while
I'll try one more time it's now soggy
though so so does anyone want to go
under this and all just and if I push
too hard
well this one's pretty good so that's
surface tension and so you can do
something like slump test to sort of
prove the cohesion as well and so this
is going to be a slump like test with
dry granda materials wet granular
materials where the water is one percent
by volume and where the water content is
five percent by volume and so what we
want to ask is which one is more stable
which leads to different flow outs and
so he's gonna flip that so you've seen
the dry one that just forms this conical
heap and then we do so that one's very
cohesive you basically keep the exact
shape of the container and then when you
add a little more water you have this
like slurry like behavior and the water
content is too much and it drains out
and so this is this cohesive behavior of
wet granular materials the next thing
that we want to talk about that allows
you to have cohesion is not from water
it's from grain shape and so a great
example of this is a bird's nest a
bird's nest if at least if it's made of
twigs and elongated particles stays
together typically without a lot of glue
and so we're going to show that in two
ways here is a little picture it's just
you throw randomly little thin rods
together I think this aspect ratio is
around 50
eighty five so it's really long the
aspect ratio means what's the ratio of
the longest dimension of the object to
the smallest dimension of the object and
this one it's 80 what is the aspect
ratio of a circle this is this one every
dimension looks the same what's the
aspect ratio of a square one every two a
good approximation they're all one but
then you get these elongated rectangles
they they can be very long and so if you
have this aspect ratio of 80
it's very cohesive but it's not cohesion
from water its cohesion from the fact
that they're intertwining and so we're
gonna do that right now a kind of a
slump test so right here inside this
tube if everybody can see I have little
Plexiglas rods and these are about 35
times as long as they are white okay so
the aspect ratio saying is variation no
tapping nothing just pour them in the
box and I'm going to remove the
container as just one test we've done
before and we're gonna see if inside I
have marbles big marbles aspect ratio
one what would happen the Marlboros will
be all over the floor and would be
picking them up for the next two hours
in this case because of the of the
entanglement of the greens because they
are all making crazy contacts we're
gonna see that it provides stability to
the pilot can you push on this one I can
push on that so this pile right here you
see that some of them were loose and
we're not making another contact with
the other so they just kind of splatter
and around scattered but most of the
piles stayed up and the angle of the
site is about 90 degrees we have a
collaborator who had one of these with
slightly longer rods they've been
hanging up from his
in Islam for two months before it
starting falling apart and it fell apart
because they were a little too much wind
and perturbation but it's very stable
structure it's actually stable somewhat
in compression so I'm going to pull down
you'll see that it's it's gonna go down
a little bit but after a while it's
gonna resist my weight so right now it's
basically resisting I can't push more
down without breaking the sticks it's
pretty stable and shear so if I just
push it around and that's basically a
very simple geometric physical
explanation of why birds nests are so
stable
I'm pushing with like I don't know five
ten pounds with my hand and this thing
is not going under it's it's it's not
complaining all birds basically we know
and on a typical bird's nest you could
sit about 6070 Birds before you're even
breaking it and those those nests from
eight four one two and a couple kids
nothing more than that so these very
simple geometric explanation mystical
explanation might be behind you know
just ability a person s that's just one
of the examples okay so one final note
so we did a lot of experiments where we
think we know the answers to the
phenomenon that we the interesting
phenomena we see but there are many more
mysteries in sand and gram materials
that are unsolved and this is one of
them
so the mystery is that sound it's called
booming booming sand dunes singing sand
dunes
and so this has been observed in you
know the Sahara Desert in the Mojave
Desert in California but it's some the
wind is picking up the grains and then
depositing them and there's this sound
that comes out and we don't really
understand what's causing it
if you were in one of these dunes in one
of this place it's about 30 places in
the world where you can find those and
Indy was I put some examples so in
Nevada and Indiana and California so
it's not completely remote part of the
world it's not just in Sahara if you
were to be on one of these dunes and
you're walking around every time you
walk you get a squeaky sound not like my
mic but real squeaky sound when you
avalanche the pile when you're on the
avalanche side of the dune so do you
know it has a flat side a plateau and on
the
site and Avalanche site which is add
that exact angle of repose we
demonstrated that's what provides that's
what gives Jews those those
characteristic shapes well you're on
that side and you're pushing the grains
now Rumble does this low sound coming in
when you walk on the on the top you'll
hear this squeaky sound it's it's pretty
it's pretty crazy closer and I've never
had a chance to go I just discovered it
this morning apparently there is a
singing Beach just singing June it
Montresor by the sea in Massachusetts so
if you ever have a chance to go up there
trying to check it out and things as
well as we're showing you right now okay
so that takes care of the dem the talk
and demonstrations today if you want to
come up and ask us questions or play
with some of the demonstrations feel
free